[Music]
hello everyone welcome my name is
Darrell Haggard I'm a faculty member in
the physics department at McGill
University and also in the McGill space
Institute and I'm here to talk to you
today about why black holes are awesome
so jRD talked a little bit this morning
about the word awesome so I mean awesome
in both its colloquial way that they're
just super cool but also that they are
really full of awe I get to study these
objects all the time and it's pretty
fantastic so I'm hoping to do a little
call in response with you also this is
partly just because I know you're
caffeinated because you just came back
from the coffee break and I only have
some calories in you so I'm gonna ask
you things like what planet do you live
on come on you can do better than that
what planet do you live on okay and so
when I ask you what are black holes
you're gonna say black holes are thank
you okay so black holes are awesome but
actually that's not even the real title
of my talk the real title of my talk Amy
Cooke our organizer thought was just a
little too glib so what I really wanted
to call this talk was black holes don't
suck and once again I mean this both in
its colloquial sense and in a real sense
that black holes are not vacuum cleaners
they do not walk through the galaxy
sucking things in that's not what
happens with black holes and so I'm
gonna try to explain and motivate this
particular sophisticated philosophy of
mine for you today
so what could start off by talking about
what is a black hole I'm gonna give you
my favorite definition you heard this a
little bit actually I think Gil hold her
in our last session was talking a bit
about escape velocities so the my
favorite definition of a black hole is
an object whose escape velocity exceeds
the speed of light so you all know about
escape velocities even if you don't know
that you know about state velocities
because you've all thrown a baseball and
what happens when I throw a baseball
falls back down I am not superhuman my
space balls just fall down in fact
they're really kind of pitiful I don't
even have a good
doing arm so if you throw a baseball it
falls back down the surface of the earth
unless you can throw it at the escape
velocity of our earth
so the escape velocity of our earth is
around 12 kilometers per second if you
can eject that baseball off the surface
of the earth at higher than 12
kilometers per second you can get it off
of the out of the gravitational
potential well we'd say of the earth so
it turns out that a black hole is an
object whose gravity is so intense it's
mass is so concentrated in such a small
volume of space that its escape velocity
in fact exceeds the speed of light and
that makes the inside of the black hole
invisible so I'd like to also borrow a
theme from dick bons talk about
simplicity and simplicity moving toward
complexity so it turns out that black
holes are some of the most simple
objects in the universe though they are
exotic and cool they can be
characterized with really only two
properties in an Astrophysical setting
their mass how much mass they contain
and their spin how rapidly they're
rotating so when we as observers I am an
observational astronomer when we go out
these are the two properties we would
like to learn about black holes in our
universe in our galaxy they do sometimes
have charged in the theoretical setting
astrophysically that gets neutralized
very quickly by material all around the
black hole so for all intents and
purposes we care about the mass and the
spin of black holes okay so I talked I
told you my very favorite definition
this notion of an escape velocity just
to throw out some of the other
terminology you might have heard before
gill also mentioned the event horizon so
this is the the radius within which
flight is trapped the sort of dimension
the the radius of the black hole that's
a term you've probably heard sometimes
you might hear of them talk to them
discussed is sort of a singularity a one
over zero kind of calculation something
that drops to infinity and this notion
of a singularity is intimately tied up
with this idea that our whole universe
is embedded in a framework which we can
refer to as space-time a sort of fabric
that is made up not only of space end of
time and when you put masses into this
fabric they slightly perturb the fabric
they change the shape of it and cause
photons cause light to move differently
this is
sort of simple artist impression of what
the Sun a white dwarf and a neutron star
might look like in the fabric of
space-time and far over here to your
right is a black hole which causes this
fabric of the universe to be so
depressed that actually that little peak
can go all the way down to infinity so
sort of a seeing an idea of a
singularity in the fabric of space-time
so they are simple but they are exotic
and we cannot see inside and so we are
left to wonder about black holes and to
learn about them by looking at their
environment looking at what happens
around the black hole as a way of trying
to get at what what these objects are in
our universe all right so just to help
you have a little bit of a scale I
talked about the earth and the escape
velocity of the earth if you were to
take our whole Earth including you and
me and all these chairs you're sitting
on and your mom and your uncle and your
friend that lives across the world you
took all of it and you smashed it down
into something right about the size of a
sugar cube that you could put into your
coffee cup right now our earth would
become a black hole so it's not so much
that the matter in the black holes is
completely different than what you and I
have here it's just that it's really
really really packed down into a very
very tiny volume so one other example if
we took our son and we smashed it down
into something the size of roughly like
a three kilometer circle around the
Ontario Science Center where we sit
right now our Sun itself would become a
black hole so you can see that these
objects here are very very very very
very very small compared to the space
that they take up in the universe and
they're kind of normal non black hole
state okay so what would happen if you
took our Sun you made it into a black
hole and you replace the Sun that we
have in the center of our solar system
with that black hole so anybody want to
venture a guess as to what would happen
to the orbits of all of our planets
here's an artist's impression of our
beautiful solar system les the Sun with
a black hole in the middle oh you guys
are so smart nothing would happen and
why would nothing happen come on what's
our name of our talk why does nothing
happen because black holes don't slack
thank you okay that's right so the
planets would stay in orbit around the
black hole because the mass of the
object the mass of the black hole that
you replace the Sun with has stayed
exact
which means the orbital the
gravitational potential well that those
planets are orbiting in is identical to
the one that it was before we would all
die a very very cold death so don't get
me wrong this would not be a happy
occurrence but indeed the orbits of the
planets would not be changed by
replacing the Sun with a black hole of
the same mass so if you'd like some more
kind of amazing and to me exotic
evidence that this is indeed true and
that we can measure this type of an
environment in our own Milky Way galaxy
I give you one of the most amazing
videos in astrophysics this is going to
be a picture of stars orbiting around
the supermassive black hole called
Sagittarius a star that lives at the
heart of our Milky Way galaxy so oh
sorry I've got black holes don't suck
okay so this is a picture that starts
you'll notice the dates it starts back
in 1995 this is a picture that colored
the sort of rainbow blobs or individual
stars whose orbits have been measured as
they orbit around an empty position in
space all of these colored lines mark
out the individual orbits the motions of
the stars over about 20 years and you
can see the little white star is there
to mark the position that is at the
focus of each one of those ellipses as
those stores of stars orbit around and
indeed we can see that these stars are
not falling to their death into the
black hole
they are stabili orbiting around this
gravitating of being object this
supermassive black hole which has four
million times the mass of our own Sun
that lives right at the heart of our
Milky Way galaxy
not only do black holes not suck they
also tend to throw things out with great
violence sometimes so this is another
amazing discovery about our own Milky
Way galaxy and we think it might be
connected back to the black hole that
lives at the heart of the galaxy these
are the so-called Fermi bubbles so this
is an artist's impression of the Farabee
bubbles with a data a picture of the
Milky Way galaxy a sort of artist's a
visualization of the Milky Way galaxy
running across the middle and these two
enormous bubbles rising up above and
below that the plane of the Milky Way's
disk so these pair me bubbles were first
detected at V
very high rate wavelet high-energy
wavelengths in the gamma ray and it
looks like these are symmetric on either
side of our galaxy and filled with this
high-energy radiation and we think that
this may be evidence that there was a
big outburst of energetic particles from
our supermassive black hole or
vicinities very very close to the
supermassive black hole in the heart of
the galaxy around ten thousand years ago
and so we can use tracers like this to
try to understand not only how mass
evolves and changes in the vicinity of a
black hole but how that black hole might
cause mass to fly out of our galaxy
in all dimensions okay so if black holes
don't suck
how exactly do black holes grow so I
told you that the supermassive black
hole at the heart of the Milky Way
galaxy is around four million times the
mass of our Sun so all that mass has to
get in there somehow and so this is the
type of science that my group does at
McGill we study how mass actually does
get into the supermassive black hole at
the heart of our Milky Way and other
supermassive black holes so this is
another artist impression of what we
call an accretion disk of mass flowing
into the black hole it's falling down
not being sucked in and that mass
actually makes it down into the black
hole because of something that you're
all very familiar with so friction if
you just rub your two hands together
they get warm if you were to look at
your hands after you do that with an
infrared camera you'll see they're
radiating a little bit extra energy you
heat it up the skin between your two
rubbing palms and that friction causes
energy to be given off it causes
particles to lose some energy and hence
to fall in to the supermassive black
hole so material does fall into the
black hole without the black hole having
to suck it in at all so these are called
accretion disks these are extremely hot
and bright because the potential well
the gravitational potential of black
holes is so very very very deep and
these accretion disks allow us to study
black holes across the universe we can
study small ones in our own galaxy we
can study the big one at the center of
our galaxy we can study big ones at the
centres of many other galaxies indeed
those are sometimes called quasars which
Jay mentioned in his introduction for
art
Horrell event today another way that
they can grow you're gonna hear about
later this afternoon this is an artist's
impression of the LIGO experiment which
showed to 30 solar mass so now not
millions but 30 solar mass black holes
in spiraling and merging together so
indeed you can grow black holes by
smashing them into one another and the
LIGO experiment is helping us understand
how often that happens in the universe
and if that is an important way of
building up the mass of supermassive
black holes at early times so can we
watch a black hole grow indeed this is a
picture a press release image from my
group this is an image at x-ray
wavelengths oh sorry the little video
doesn't keep running um so we'll go back
here this is an x-ray image the big
multicolored image is a multi wavelength
view of our galactic center this is the
center of our Milky Way galaxy the
emission that you're seeing here is
dominated by hot gas by stars forming by
stars exploding which lares builds soon
we'll talk about soon and I'll play this
video for you one more time but while I
have the still image up I will point out
that this blue thing here is actually a
source of x-ray emission but it is not
the supermassive black hole this blue
thing is actually a magnetic neutron
star a magnetic pulsar which is one of
the areas of expertise of Viki Casspi
who will be talking last in our session
this morning and it's really close to
the supermassive black hole so close
it's actually kind of hard to see them
apart so I'll play the video for you one
more time here you see this bright flash
you guys see that bright flash that's
actually a little tiny outburst from the
supermassive black hole which is sitting
very close to this magnetar so I'm sad J
star you can't you can't see it right
now but the bright flash would be right
where the magnet are where the sad J
star arrow is pointing and the other
blue dot is coming from the magnetar so
I will just say that there are some
other exciting experiments coming up on
the extent horizon telescope is linking
together radio telescopes across the
globe to help us get an image of the
supermassive black hole and I was going
to compare this to it hare if you
imagine me plucking a piece of my hair
and somebody at the very back of the
room trying to look at that hair it
would cover one arcsecond of angle the
event horizon telescope has to get one
millionth of that angular resolution in
order
actually take a picture of the
supermassive black hole at the center of
our galaxy so these are artist
impressions of this experiment taking
place just this spring trying to
actually take a picture of accretion
onto a supermassive black hole right
here in our Milky Way galaxy so I will
leave you and I would like you all to
remember number one that black holes are
and that black holes thank you
[Applause]